Megan mark Ola and Prince Harry get  close during the Invictus games the 36  year old suit star and her royal man are  no longer hiding their love the two have  been spotted out in about holding hands  smiling and cheering on vets all week  long  during Harry's third annual event for  wounded veterans in Toronto Canada and  during closing ceremonies on Saturday  the pair proved they're totally in love  cozying up together Harry even leaned in  for a smooch  while he held her close before the  couple showed their adorable PDA Megan  and her mom Maria Ragland were seen in  the stands clapping for Harry and the  Invictus game at least while the prince  took the stage to congratulate them  [Music]  you